You go. So by the.
So seven the losses in the
ambulance. I was about 25.
But i was able to do it with. The. Yes.
Yes it was just a macfarlane m-c.
If they are a any joes. Jamie.
If you go oh my name is jan i worked here
during the aquarius testable for the
aquarius sun shine and went away for
five years and then i came back
and had children and haven't really gone
anywhere. I now manage a local business.
My name's jay
and i also worked on
the aquarius festival.
At the end of the first lie to run away
as far as i could somehow ended up back
here again
and i have my own business within
the terms of the original stories
you came early the truth the
whole truth the truth is i know
you know that but i can't.
Write accidentally accidentally if
things are really accidents anymore
and i don't know if that's the case but.
I had already been in north queensland
from about 18 months after dropping out of
sydney and came back to sydney because
at first when you leave the city.
You don't know how to survive really.
And my skills were coming quite slowly
and so i had to do a couple of forays
back to the city and on one of them.
I ran into my friend precious who
said. We're going to nimbin course.
For you know what for.
So he explained about the festival and
what was going to likely to happen
and we want to come and work i was also
in sydney with a friend of mine who deal.
And so we said yes and we
again went back to queensland
and then came down specially to work
on the first of all in the january.
Well we were very idealistic then
probably idealistic as well as fairly
footloose and fancy free. You know
if something sounds exciting.
Because we weren't employed.
We could just go there
and fairly feel a sense both in those
days to a lot of courage around.
Well i had just returned home from
india and i was in a spot of trouble.
I suppose you could say and it
was a way out and i had friends
that were living here and so i
disappeared and made myself very scarce.
I wasn't do you know. So.
So i came here and moved into a
band with a number of people.
Jay being one of them
and we worked on setting up the rainbow
cafe which was really good fun.
We did used to spend a lot of
time. Cuddling one another.
You know playing your
cooking and cuddling yes.
High priorities was one of the biggest
features of the festival was the amount of
cuddling that people did it was
definitely in the days of flower power.
And mount of life solution we went to
lasting each other because everybody would
catch you out thing
and i really really like well i do it
for the truck to come in from broome.
And the truck driver who was a little bit.
Slow used to call out in
the middle of the street.
I've got to go running
but everyone would be infected again like
having days i dribbled all over india
and never caught me
and i couldn't believe it they would
be virtually jumping off the air.
But i mean really. They were going to
know them before they were airbrushes
and you know. Yeah there
were then yeah with many.
Funky i think you know. You know.
Well everyone was very into hair which
you boys was a terrible example.
But there was a great deal of fun.
There was a lot of lovely
sharing lots of campfires
and a lot heaping usually can be management
was a great film was really good
because most of us came out of
a nuclear family isolation.
So this was where it was really.
And it was around the time
when our bid was really really being
discovered on a large scale with young people
and so there was an enormous amount
of heart opening and people thought
that this was like the best
thing that it ever happened
and turned in i think a lot
of people have said to me
that it was a turning point in their lives
and that their attitudes changed at
that point in time a massively
formulated new attitude
that maybe they have used as a basis for
how they've conducted themselves from here
on in.
A lot of groups a lot of things
done in circles a lot of sharing.
I think also taking mushrooms
together and working stories.
Tellings lots of story telling and
and finding value in your own story which
i think what's so great about what you're
doing too because it does it gives value
to people's lives to hear their own
stories and it also gives value to your
life when you stop and look at why you do.
Things or not.
Makes a special focus
there is great stuff.
I am very much.
And there were a lot of evenings held at
the rainbow cafe were with people who were
involved in the setting up of the
festival who would get up and sing
and encourage others to sing so there was
a lot of that sort of group sharing that.
Maybe people hadn't really experienced
that before us day said we came out
of news to families i mean you know.
Obviously a lot of people had experienced
before they came here but by
and large i think we were city people
with very little experience of
that extended sharing we had maybe
community households in sydney
but you didn't tend to meet him
really large groups of people
and doug was a big part of it to a lot
of people getting stoned together
and taking mushrooms and.
I suppose mind expansion in a
sense before it became dreary
and i say it was a real
space where you could play.
Yeah you know because it was like revisiting
childhood we've often talked about
this and realize the value there
was great. Worth in that because.
We did have that we took
that time and we were given
that time just to reconnect with all
our friends over a period of months
and basically we just played
we have the best fun.
Even as well as learn a yeah we will learn
new skills because we saw the rainbow.
We set up the craft center and then i went
and worked on the offset printing press
which i'd never considered before you know
and i had a rude comment actually
when we were paid a name
and dollar a day which is just to
print the money. If you'd been good.
Even if i could base
everybody enough food.
I never one day buying enough
to defeat 15 pino online to us
and right now they're to spread dollars
and i thought you know you've got a gold.
Today for working on the festival.
Yeah but we printed
and you know i don't even have one i want
you know michael was asking the day.
Who's got it. Oh i've never even
heard of them lose god and him and.
We never even got to keep
some you know i mean
that for the money we had we had no
social no work no you're actually really
and we had no drugs.
So you know a dollar a
day was really vital
and so you never got to keep
it you know living. One up.
So we had a truck a big truck that we got
to brisbane in and bought by you know
but you know when the market. Yeah.
So that was a big adventure
that a number of the said go with the truckie
whose name is harry who had grown up
in an old people's home
and used to tell the most amazing stories
he was very old man himself so he was a
young man but he talked
like a really old man
and he would talk literally
from the moment you left him
and tell them until we got to
prison and all the way back.
So we were jockey for position.
And we talked frightfully slow.
You know
and if he was only had no courage
to me in this i looked under.
God i think one of them just died the other
day a man named dudley who was a fairly
old man and we think he was in and roger
the man that runs you know i mean he's.
You know no no no no no.
And i don't live in an
old man with white hair
that lived over time
you know you know and.
Roger came after the first time
and he loosened back you know he started
you know he started the craft he just made
you. Great. So.
Well by the time the festival came around.
We had established quite a strong bond
between people considering how many people
worked on the setting up and i think
that the arguments were there in munich
really there was a pretty good feeling
among. Them. It was a feeling
like an extended family the band
that we lived in i guess there would
have been 15 maybe even sometimes more
something like around here surrounding the
barn there were little tiny pig sheds
and old cow bales which we
had all turned into a home
and people had put up tents and things.
And so
that was just one portion of it now a lot
of i thought i was it later called the
magic circle. Jill and i made
were given the job of sewing.
A dozen i think tepees out of canvas
for the first foundation which we did
and for doing that we were
able to keep one each.
And we set up done in the magic circle
we actually moved out of this house
that we started in
and so there are lots of you know
looked into alternate housing
and lots of alternate healing.
So we ran in as although not in a hollow
tree down in the paddock down here
and they went they have
moved away from here.
They've gone to live in bali and england
and she eventually started the birth
and beyond here in them
and their beginnings were as
acupuncturists in this hollow tree.
Are you fairly. Yeah very close
and you get most of the time you know
it makes you know mostly naked and
and loaded like everything.
Yeah it will never come again.
No i don't even the children who i see in
the street who are trying to recreate it
through their dress and and
maybe some of their ideals.
I don't think it can ever be like
that again because there's a
certain innocence is lost. Now.
That we had. Yeah i mean surely
i hope for the children.
I do as well i think it's dreadful. I
feel at that point in our lives and.
We were very optimistic
and there was a hope
that things would get better because
it was as i said the flower power days
and people were ultimately optimists.
That society would as we knew
it would break down and out of
that would come a new order
and possibly a much better
attitude towards the planet
and towards one another
as people and in england.
I should say that i won't say that
i won't say it's to. The work.
I do. There is there's a heap. You know.
And i just think we're a bit slow on the
uptake i'm just seeing a great need in
nimbin not so much now for the tourism
which people have been really focusing on
but for the children things for the
children to do focus is for them
and fun for them because they are on a dance
studio down the hill in the showground
and. We have a great time together
and i'd say about 150 children passed
through there a week if not more.
Maybe pre-school class and swimmers
and that's from too used to 16.
We have with.
I would say so you know you know. Yeah yeah
yeah i feel that there's a lot of well.
Reticence about celebrating aquarius in a
state the town is in which is sad because
it's such a worry to most of the
people that live here that.
Feel helpless because we basically
have this tenant of leniency.
Tolerance is sort of like our cameras
and it always has been since the days
when we first came here because and
if you think about the old settlers
that lived here in this
very quiet rural area
and a bunch of crazy hippies with the bum
hanging out their trousers literally
moved in on them and they
were very tolerant of us
and a lot of those people have stayed
and have become longtime residents
and have a good relationship with
the old residents in the town
but the new young kids that
are or the new wave of people
that have moved into them
and with the arts hang out of their trousers
who are using drugs and selling them.
Straight those old residents really out
there terrified at making them worry
that and knowledge about in their
bed at night and wonder whether
or not the streets safe
and that's not nice.
I mean that's our tolerance gone haywire.
But basically we don't
know what to do about it.
I certainly don't know anything that's been
even gender today. Doesn't sound right.
Like the police coming in dealing
with it was cutting them all off
and you think well where are they going
to go you know what can you do for them
about that. I mean they come here because
of the time and you don't you know.
That it's it's kind of turned against us.
Really you know which is very sad and
that's i think it's sad altogether is
that lack of loss of innocence because
and what the outcome of that.
Well again i could come back to.
A focus on facilities for these
people if they're going to be here.
Then we need to be able to deal
with in some way that helps
and not just cut them out further
so when you gets harder and harder.
Maybe a million creative approach
to it but once again you know
that would take some body of responsible
people to take down and funding
and say well. You know really funding.
You know because we're not much richer
financially monetarily was richer in spirit
but. Still you know.
Going to college which.
Works so well it's sort of.
Still a pocket of
idealism when it comes to
that because i think as a lot of people
have ended up on communities and.
Built their own homes and
live fairly low cost life.
You know we do we certainly do and
we know lots of people like that.
You know and that feels great.
And that's the way
that we deal with being able to settle for
a much lower income is because we've got
a much you know this. Costing weekly
yearly you know i mean it's just.
We've set up. That sort of lifestyle.
So we don't draw on too much resources
of the planet. You know do you forget.
You.
Well whenever i have of being making
breakfast in the rainbow one morning i was
making on that
and a friend of mine came in with a box
of a hatful of freshly picked gold tops
which you then put into my
omelet mixture which we all 8
and we were in the process of making a
craft video for the sydney university
without the back we were doing
a spinning it like many was.
And i got in i was spinning
and i was so loaded.
I couldn't by the end of it as i did
you see if i think i better go home.
I can't focus. Oh you got some good.
Oh to do by blowing the paint
on did you think something
and it was just i was just the
whole force. That was good.
So you know i remember a friend
of ours who was pregnant.
This may have just been after aquarius.
And she was very pregnant
and she was playing in the creek down the
bottom near the magic circle down the
bottom of the creek and she stood on a
stone fish and you know what if you know
that you know a bull rabble rouser
and she school re-aim turn
down your journals factor.
Trudy factor off
and she was carried by freedom as is about
six foot three the whole lent the road
and up the town to the hospital
screaming her lungs out
and point you know nearly had a big
fat blubbery when you sit here.
That was funny. I remember that.
Yes i remember going out with a whole bunch
of us in the truck to a country dance
right out in the middle of nowhere. I
wouldn't to this day know where i was.
And it was all the old timers
having a bath. I'm down.
So we were invited and it was the
most beautiful night they danced
and band dances and then gave a source
guns and tea and there was just period.
I'd never seen anything quite like it
but we have actually through the connections
in the pub some very good friends of
the older residents in the town.
Because there weren't such a great
many of us at the beginning
and kneeled. For a horseman.
And i remember going to the
races with jewels and precious
and before we went to the races we saw no
where we'd better get some good closer
into some venues and we found these
three immaculate pinstripes.
And we'd all at
that point in time cut our hair
off like short of the mind is now
and we all called us selves bruce and
when pinstripes not should do so
and it was it was great. Me introduced
us to everybody and brought us beers.
We had the best time we didn't even on
that were all called bruce
that's really funny.
They used to be music in the pub
in the front by the pub here
and we did used to dance. We often
wore a bit and brace overalls
that was kind of our uniform and then we
all blotched with paint and embroidered
and things and we would dance with
the local fellows and they thought
that was great. They've got all their
christmas is a commitment i think.
Partially they have a really good concerts
in the town hall too because of the
white company. And that was great. Fun.
They used to just come up with all sorts
of amazing things breaking new ground in
the theatre and so that was excellent.
We still have some very
nice time you know.
And. Well it was just sort
of part of the creek. So.
To do it right the magic circle was.
There's just this very
beautiful bend in the creek
and it made quite a like a
semicircle and then me and it on.
So when all the dwellings were put there.
It was like a little circle
and in the centre was a big
trench for the cooking fires
and just use the water from the creek.
It was just a very nice place
and course everyone would see
it outside their dwellings and.
And it made the most of
that was the magic so there was
a sauna down there was a sauna
and so we would have hot soreness
and then leak in the creek and.
That's when two got bitten by the ball
when we were doing something like that.
And again just everywhere there
was music. I remember in may.
It was quite cold
and the mists would come up because there's
lots of creeks through here at the back
and then this would car
and you'd be stumbling there's hardly anybody
even owned a torch you know we didn't
know anything much at all
and your big stumbling through the
muse to just missing the creek
or falling over somebody fallen over. It
was very funny and you come into these.
Tense situations or just you know what.
However people had set up some sort
of shelter and little tiny lights
and then you discover all the faces and
there'll be music happening and those.
I remember there was one
lovely one over there and
that guy was there who had made all these
musical instruments the craziest musical
instruments you know we sort of
have to stretch the necks of things
and some were wonderful and
that was one of the best places
to go night was really fun.
So it just stayed on for us
and i for short period of time and
then i went to northern queensland.
Yes that we stayed to
help with the cleaning.
I stayed till august also my friend
jill was having a. Baby jinky was born.
In june july 2 lines.
She was born in july and we waited
until jinky was big enough to travel
and we went back to queensland through.
You know.
So i returned about 16 years ago maybe 15
years ago. You know 15 years ago.
And i had been living in an
asia and america and japan and.
I came back to australia wanting
to settle and have children.
And the only place i thought about was going
was no because the midwife who i spoke
about that lived in the hollow
tree had since become a midwife
and i knew that's what i wanted to do so.
I came back and headed straight for
them and they were friends of mine
and we lived in
and one of the original farm houses in
niman out on our edge smith road belong to
one of the original settlers of an emilia
them i think never sent old farmhouse.
And we came and lived
back there and i taught
but i opened about exterior
for a little while and.
Gone very far since then i
go seeds every now and again
and i say i just settled had
tilled and reared children
and still make craft. You feel you.
Do you know. Yeah we built a house area.
We live on the road community
we've got to yes it was built.
So. Oh oh golly i think before
my husband and i lived there.
We lived in about seven places around
england a number of them one of them was.
On a community was grand dunstan
and at the time his wife five
and their children so
that was the early days
when people were beginning to have their
babies at home there was a very big well
once again i think the idealist.
Attitude towards having babies at home
building your homes green veggies gardens
and orchards. Well that was
very viable thing to do
and i think there were something
like 200 babies born in the area
that were born at home
and we would often attend one another's
births sometimes i would go with carol
climbing mountains in the middle of
the night as her birthing assistant.
So there was a still even in those days
with my fantastic feeling in this town.
We had a folk club that people would
come from far and wide to be a part of
and it was just wonderful
cost a dollar to get in
and people who you wouldn't even
know were performers would get up
and just surprise you with the most
viewed of music was really good fun
and even in those days i think it was still
very hard to get so social security.
So there was a lot of sharing
people which share vehicles.
You know there was work days more
days and there was a lot of sharing
that took place as well.
The start of the home but
i think movement was.
Carol elliott who was a
trained acupuncturist
and very interested in homoeopathy
who had had four children herself.
She was alone midwife she had i think
she's since a qualified midwife
and you went to london and
got her qualifications
but at the time she was a lady midwife
and she would go to people's
places very inaccessible.
Like i mean i remember one birth she went
to right at the end of the governess
valley and it was during a wet season and
the lady couldn't get out and so carol
and her men norman waited the creek and
it was one of those extended labors
and so basically they would just go to
people's homes and they would set up camp
and sometimes they'd be there
for days and. You know p.
Would have their babies the way they
wanted to which was very soft lighting.
And the ents that and you weren't
hurried my first child was born out it.
Excellent in the farmhouse it carol.
And norman and i lived in the
labor was very easy six hours.
I had people sitting in
the room meditating.
He was born
and then later started in the early hours
of the morning his phone at lunch time
and it was just no hurry.
Nobody has so do i done a
lot of reading and i think
that was the thing most women
that were compared to have their babies
at home really took responsibility for
educating themselves about the process. So
even though i don't know what to expect.
I basically knew what was going to happen
and carol was very telepathic woman she
were just a highly intuitive highly
intuitive and she was told you don't have
that yet. And you know intuits what next.
You would do you know wave a pendulum over
your belly to see where you were right
at what stage you laver
and you know she'd give you some homeopathic
so she would basically just talk about
and do what she had to do and when the
birth was over you'd all drink champagne
and eat chocolate cake
or fruit cake with a favorite you
were said to bake bread cake for her
but she did in fact deliver many
of the children that people.
Gave names too like rain for them softly
inside and things like my sons of god.
Jesse and right.
And very beautiful children
and in those days everyone was having babies
there was a really big baby boom here
and so there was a lot of community.
Living and with small children and
we would start play groups together
and basically share.
Its return.
Well she worked on a donation basis
and unfortunately that's where
things really went wrong.
I feel because she was often people would
come from a long way away to have their
baby and they would end
up staying with carol
and they wouldn't have much in the way
of money so they'd either pay her with
cabbages or you know barter something and.
They eventually got to the point where
carolyn and i couldn't live like
that anymore. And after having that
happen to them for years on end they felt
that they she didn't have to shouldn't
have had to be on the dole doing what they
were doing and in any other place
they wouldn't have had that abused
but unfortunately it did become difficult
for them so they ended up going to live
in london and can very well known
very famously made a lot of money.
Was there.
But it was done on a barter
system really i think.
Almost 30 years. Well that's right.
But you know it's got to be the best
injury and the best my second child.
I think i think so. It was
a room. You know bigger.
Maybe as big as this room
here which is what 12 by 10
and there were 18 people there
five of them were children.
My oldest son jesse was a
birth attendant he looked.
I mean he couldn't get any closer. He gave
a running commentary like money at this.
Everybody if it's not like that
and my brother and i took photos
and he would have been rightly you almost
between my legs i mean he got the most
expressive birth photos and
i didn't even notice him.
There were people everywhere
and would just you know ways to
say it's like a birthday party
but it was so personal and so intense
that it really didn't matter and each
and every one of those people has a connection
with my children unless they got to
be president. We just have a birth
recently on rob road. Most recent birth.
And. Marilyn's eldest son is 15.
And who next about it and this baby came
and you show me sitting at the bottom of
the bed saying this is not my mother's
best feature but there are things like
that with the room again you know like
it's so you just get drawn there you know
you think. Yes ok i will only.
These people will come but.
Who then has the baby come you know
or nearly nearly you know on the energy
so intense that you can't walk away.
So by the end of
that birthing there was a whole lot of
bounce around with semicircle around the
bottom of the bed and quite
a few mainly aldrin who
and all the kids you know who went to
school the next day for their personal
development class and said.
Experience best personal development
we've ever had the baby.
Because of us and indeed.
Yeah it's wonderful here
and then we would have blessing ceremonies
there was one absolutely beautiful one
where i fact there's been many of them where
mark visited this erica that's another
thing
that people know a lot of people around
this area into meditation of some sort
and so we get incredible visits
from very high spiritual beings
and on a couple of occasions we've had
them do naming ceremony for our children
where people from far and
wide would bring their babies
and they would be given a spiritual
name and then there'd be a celebration
and a blessing and a very
beautiful. Yeah. Those.
You know that the post office that
has been committed is around.
This a smith who used around the
post of an im and he was a saint.
He was ready for retirement. So
he figured he would by himself.
The smallest post-office he could
find and retired to nimbin.